so you're returning back and then the
skills are different the workplace is
different and it's quite scary Karen
Tyndall is 62 years old and wants to
work so she's come here to this drop-in
center in Liverpool for help and advice
on how best to do it
the chancellor has announced measures to
get people back to work including those
over 50. so-called return ships and even
skills boot camps Karen says she likes
the sound of it so you would think that
the government are on the right Lines by
saying look yet we we need to do more we
need to get the over 50s skills get back
into work and do some in real life I
think it's great but I don't think that
with people should be on the minimum
wage
so not just any job a good quality
meaningful job absolutely yeah the best
job
how are all the people give them the
best opportunities by being in that job
Britain's tied labor market is the
backdrop Behind these measures with
nearly a fifth of the working age
population in the UK economically
inactive the chancellor needs to make it
easier for women in particular to get
back into work brilliant if Government
can put into places additional support
however we're concerned because it just
looks like it's a package that's been
thrown together there needs to be
significant investment into these
women's Economic Development so if local
and national government don't
significantly invest into their skills
development and offer more support
packages for women than the unemployment
and economically inactive rate is going
to stay high and it's going to keep
Rising
this is important because Britain is
actually in the grip of a Workforce
crisis with companies trying to fill
around a million vacancies this isn't
just about people finding jobs this is
the Cornerstone of the government's
ambition to drive the economy but while
much of the government's strategy is
focused on older people it didn't offer
much for the young the 16 to 24 year
olds
Sky Duffy is 17. she's desperate to
learn more and achieve her ambition of
becoming a journalist so you've got a
chance to watch the budget what was your
initial reaction when you when you saw
it it was honestly quite disappointing
because a whole generation was missed
out on the budget you know people my age
are trying to navigate life becoming an
adult you know people are applying for
uni through ucas or trying to get
apprenticeships and I feel like there
was no guidance given to people our age
and there was like no government support
the chancellor is trying to increase
employment but it's not easy
redundancies are up wages are stagnating
and a recession looms McMartin Sky News
Liverpool